et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick kanner bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur du nord
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par julien lécuyer la voix du nord
bonjour oriane bonjour julien gens me
scanner vos jour j on commence par
airbus le groupe européen qui a annoncé
hier soir la suppression de 15000
emplois en europe dont 5000 emplois en
france est ce que comme bercy vous jugé
ce chiffre excessif a plus les chiffres
parce qu'une entreprise qui est
florissante qui certes a connu comme
tout le monde aujourd'hui une difficulté
au travers du confinement mais c'est une
entreprise qui est un des fleurons de la
france et de l'europe
donc là on profite de la situation très
ponctuel pour pour dégraisser permettez
moi l'expression est donc j'espère que
le que l'état aura plus que son mot à
dire pour dire non un plan social d'une
telle importance c'est une saignée
énorme 5000 emplois en france c'est
scandaleux je le dis très très
simplement camouflet vis-à-vis de l'état
qui décide des plans sectoriels qui
dépense c'est qu'un à 15 milliards 1 le
plan de la filière aéronautique c'est
une provocation je suis d'accord avec
vous une provocation
ah oui c'est une provocation donc alors
je pense que c'est en demande 5 ans 10 à
1000 pour avoir moins mais voilà on ne
joue pas avec l'avenir des salariés avec
l'avenir de père et de mère de famille
comme ceux là donc je suis vraiment très
très choqués et nous le dirons
naturellement et voilà nous ne sommes
pas aux affaires que sont la femme
consacrée j'espère que bercy mais aussi
le chef de l'état prendra sa part parce
que encore une fois quand on voit les
résultats de bercy y compris j'ai
regardé par aya par aya par hasard je
fais aussi mal ce matin par hasard
le cours de bourse c'est intéressant il
a monté hier comme par hasard donc non
je veux dire vraiment les pouvoirs
publics a abandonné doivent intervenir
pour empêcher ce qui constitue
manifestement pour l'ensemble du monde
salarié j'ai dit le mot provocation mais
quelque part la remise en cause
finalement de notre modèle social mais
finalement ça ne remet pas en cause le
monde de le monde d'avant qui qui va
ressembler fort quand même moment deux
au monde d'après parce que le c'est
business as usual pour les entreprises
j'ai parlé bien l'anglais j'étais
présent il ya une semaine exactement
avec le président de république à ce
déjeuner où il a réuni les présidents de
groupe autour de gérard larcher il a dit
mais les plans sociaux c'est trop facile
pour une fois je suis d'accord avec lui
c'est trop facile parce qu'on se dit on
se débarrasse de salariés et c'est là
c'est l'assurance chômage qui prendra en
charge
non je crois que quand on a des
difficultés économiques le chef
d'entreprise qui a su et nous l'avons
soutenu bénéficier de l'assurance
chômage partiel doit aussi rendre des
comptes et rendre des comptes c'est
prendre part à ce qu'on appelle le
verrez se prendre part finalement bon
fonctionnement de la société
et là c'est trop simple effectivement
que le dire on se sépare de 15 mille
salariés dont 5000 en france air france
qui annoncera également un plan vendredi
on parle de 7500 emplois qui seraient
menacés chez air france air france et 7
milliards dette de l'état pendant la
crise sanitaire est ce que là aussi vous
demander au chef de l'état d'intervenir
et de dire pas de suppressions seront
prêts pour être plus précis c'est pas
c'est pas une recapitalisation
je pense que la bonne solution et était
de recapitaliser air france avec donc
une montée en puissance de la part de
l'état ce qui a moins vu hors éviter ce
type de décision alors je ne dis pas qu
air france se doit ne doit pas regard
peut-être de ce qui s'est passé revisité
son fonctionnement on parle d des lignes
courtes etc
mais sur les suppressions d'emplois
celle ci avait des annonces de 7500
suppressions d'emplois qu'est ce que
vous direz vendredi en tout cas si c'est
confirmé j'aurais dû vous dirai la même
chose que j'ai évoquée sur ce que
j'évoquais sur airbus considère
qu'aujourd'hui
l'état et notamment encore plus sûre sur
air france au regard de l'aide qu'il a
apportée au regard des prêts qu'ils
apportaient doit avoir un droit de
regard
finalement l'ancien monde que dénonce
monsieur macron en tout cas qui évoque
les schémas cran c'est un monde où il ya
un équilibre et où la démarche de l'état
et protectrice du bon fonctionnement de
la société et de l'économie si monsieur
macron considère que finalement c'est
une méthode intéressante et bien nous
serons à ses côtés non pas pour le
soutenir mais en tout cas pour
l'encourager à ne pas laisser faire
n'importe quoi dans notre pays et vous
parliez de ces suppressions de
l'intérieur elles sont demandées par une
partie de la gauche par les écologistes
notamment est-ce que de facto ce n'est
pas ça qui crée des suppressions
d'emplois chez air france
mais les lignes intérieures sur des
temps de distance de deux heures et
demie en train chacun peut comprendre
que c'est un coup c'est un luxe
aujourd'hui au regard de la population
environnementale donc mais est-ce qu air
france peut imaginer d'autres formules
diversification peut-être de ses
services en tout cas pas de
licenciements secs
c'est l'entreprise qui devra gérer cette
solution a parlé d'un anti g autre
actualité
hier soir agnès buzyn l'ex ministre de
la santé a été interrogé par la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
lcl a démenti avoir été responsable en
tant que ministre de la gestion des
démasqué ce que vous avez été convaincu
par ces explications n'ont non enfin je
donne sur l'explication mais en tant que
ministre
sur un sujet aussi important après avoir
connu la polémique que nous avons
connues sur les masques mais inutile au
départ et maintenant voilà chacun porte
portent des masques
on voit bien que c'est courage fuyons et
en dix ans mais c'est mon administration
qui n'a pas prévenu mais connaissez la
formule peut être pas coupable mais
responsable
donc elle est responsable de ce qui
c'est
passé je ne dis pas que elle porte dans
cette responsabilité la disparition de
milliers de nos concitoyens dans la
crise de la commune 19
mais néanmoins on ne peut pas dire je ne
savais pas il ya eu des erreurs de la
part de la gestion de crise c'est qu'on
va lancer la nôtre commission denquête
les masques ont déjà été évoquées par la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale bien sûr qu'il ya eu des
insuffisances pas moi qui le dit c'est
le président de la république
c'est hier à l'occasion du débat sur la
proposition de résolution qui crée la
commission denquête au sénat je les dis
j'ai rappelé les mots exacts du
président lors de son discours du 13
rbds et louis dit oui manifestement on
n'a pas été à la hauteur
si si je résume bien si le président le
dit je pense que ces ministres devraient
être moins solidaires de leur président
de la république entre léa de leur
ancien président pour ce qui concerne
l'année ce bouzin préparation du système
de santé antérieurs à emmanuel macron
cet après midi c'est marisol touraine
qui sera devant la commission de
l'assemblée nationale
sk pas aussi une responsabilité des
socialistes dans le manque de
préparation du système de santé
écoutez sur la question des masques et
les chiffres là sont imparables
il y avait 750 millions de masques
disponibles à la fin du quinquennat de
françois hollande 750 millions 754
millions pour être précis et j'ai des
contacts qui le voilà qui le
démontreront vous verrez que les preuves
seront apportées on a détruit des
masques parce qu'ils étaient périmés
elle l'a dit d'ailleurs agnès buzyn le
problème n'est pas de savoir si on a
détruit des masques
c'est la question c'est pourquoi on les
a pas remplacés et manifestement camp
le premier ministre vient s'exprimer
devant les français lors de ses
conférences de presse il dit mais au
début de la pandémie qui datent donc
autour du 24 25 janvier pandémie
reconnue par les pouvoirs publics il n'y
avait que 117 millions de masques donc
on a détruit des masques on ne les a pas
remplacés il ya donc une faute une faute
qu'il faut qu'ils feront grèce mais
pourquoi ne pas le dire tout simplement
on a fait une erreur on est remplaçant
qui naquit a commencé sous le sous le
mandat de hollande parce que
antérieurement il y avait quand même 1,4
milliard evans et de masques et on est
passé à 700 millions c'est à dire que
c'est vrai à destruction et la ne le non
renouvellement à wizz largement
installée durant deux mandats de
françois hollande il ya eu une
diminution de nombre de masques mais une
chute brutale excusez moi au début du
quinquennat de d'emmanuel macron alors
je ne dis pas que ces manuels macron il
ya le musée qui ont décidé mais leur
administration qui parfois d'ailleurs
est la même que celle qui existait avec
françois hollande et marisol touraine
disons le clairement mais un moment
donné il n'y a pas eu la bonne décision
qui aurait dû être prise est la bonne
décision c'était ont détruit des masques
mais on n'en recommande immédiatement
pour reconstituer le stock
monsieur carrier ont parlé rien de
parler de l'aide de la création de la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
on va avoir donc trois commissions qui
vont s'attarder sur la gestion du duc au
vide une deux par le national une
sollicités par le gouvernement et une
par le sénat est ce que nul n'est pas
sauvé la maison c'est le gouvernement en
position d'en quête personnelle oui mais
est ce qu'on n'en fait pas trop dedans
gate est ce que l' enquête uppal enquête
non jeu très honnêtement
on a eu quand même quelques expériences
récentes heureusement qu'il y avait
aussi la commission dite benalla parce
que celle de l'assemblée a explosé en
plein vol dans les conditions que vous
savez il ya une de trop c'est celle du
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
peut pas être juge et partie on ne
s'auto évalue pas
moi je le dis très simplement quand il y
a un pouvoir de contrôle qui existe au
sein du parlement
moi je ne suis pas choqué qu'il y ait
deux commission denquête à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec les mêmes solutions
parce que ça permet de comparer
finalement les résultats de ces
auditions auprès finalement du grand
public où seront totalement transparents
les auditions seront publiques ça veut
dire que n'importe quel français y
compris ceux qui ont pu être touchés par
la crise de la covin même dans leur
chair au travers de la perte d'un proche
est bien pouvant se dire mais voilà
notre démocratie fonctionne elle
contrôle l'exécutif est ce qu'un jour
dans une réforme constitutionnelle il
faudrait imaginer des commissions de
contrôle commune mixte voulu dire
pourquoi pas il ya bien des commissions
mixtes paritaires pour statuer sur le
devenir des lois moi ça ne me choquerait
pas mais ce n'est pas possible pour
l'instant de la constitution on va
parler de ce qui se passe au sénat cet
après-midi avec deux textes notamment un
projet de loi sur la perte d'autonomie
qui prévoit la création d'une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale dédié
justement à cette perte d'autonomie vous
vous êtes favorable à la création de
cette cinquième rang j'aimerais ça fait
ça fait presque 20 ans que je suis
favorable puisque quand je te présenter
un texte actuel parce que le financement
est reportée à plus tard oui oui non
m'effacer c'est du pipeau ou quoi disons
le clairement c'est du pipeau ce cas
dans le texte est attaché bien sûr
puisqu'il n'ya pas de deux de
financement assuré une cinquième branche
c'est quoi c'est d'expliquer aux
français que la dépendance n'est pas un
risque c'est une certitude
chacun d'entre nous est indépendante
potentiel avec l'avancement en âge et
que nous avons tous dans notre périmètre
de proximité avec nos familles nos
proches nous avons des personnes qui
sont dépendantes soit en raison de leur
âge soit en raison d'un handicap
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un cinquième
risque est ce que c'est qu'une
prestation en la matière se le dire la
sécurité sociale prend en charge ce
risque potentiel qui bien souvent
certains pour beaucoup d'entre nous et
d'ailleurs si en 1945 quand on crée la
sécurité sociale avec ses quatre
branches
on avait eu là la même situation
qu'aujourd'hui vous croyez que
le législateur de l'époque n'aurait pas
créer immédiatement la cinquième branche
bien sûr qu'il aurait fait mais il
aurait fait dans les conditions de
l'époque c'est-à-dire avec des
cotisations clairement identifié il ya
moi je vous le dis ici à ce micro les
français sont capables d'entendre que
pour se protéger de cette risque de la
dépendance
ils sont capables de dire mais je suis
prêt à y contribuer au travers de mes
cotisations salariales mais aussi bien
sûr travers des cotisations patronales
oui je pense que les français sont
responsables sont pas des enfants et que
quand on a quand on tire en permanence
sur la notion d' impôts quand on dit
mais l'impôt c'est pas bien si l'impôt
direct ou indirect permet de d'avoir une
société protectrice
je pense que c'est un message qui est
compris aujourd'hui par par les français
c'est ce que vous attendez de la
conférence de financement ce que
j'espère c'est que l'on mette les 7 8 9
milliards nécessaires pour créer ce
fameux c'est un must cinquième branche
d'un milliard pour le moment pour vous
et pas suffire c'est pas suffisant il ya
tous les spécialistes le savent bien et
je ne veux pas qu'on la présente comme
étant une charge parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que la prise en charge de la
dépendance
c'est de la création d'emplois ça veut
dire que chaque personne dépendante à
grosso modo la capote est créé pour elle
même un emploi donc ça crée de la
richesse sacré de la ressource à créer
des recettes pour la sécurité sociale
donc ce n'est pas une charge c'est un
modèle de société dont nous aurions
aujourd'hui à le mettre en place et ne
pas finalement laissé au choix des uns
des autres
finalement ceux qui peuvent se produire
dépendance sont les plus aisés mais j'ai
juste pour qu'on soit clair cet après
midi vous voterez pour en évidence et
déjà un premier mois je suis pour le
prince il ya pas de financement mais
voilà et on votera pour parce que
ça va ça a inscrit dans le marbre le
principe mais je pense que ce
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui aura à
gérer notamment le ruissellement de la
dette publique ne mettra pas les moyens
nécessaires et les moyens nécessaires
c'est encore une fois ce discours de
vérité aux français à savoir de le
financer par de la cotisation et on peut
faire confiance aux pensées encore une
fois pour comprendre que cela est
nécessaire dans notre pays
ça veut dire hausse des cotisations
jusqu'au bout bien sûr mais ça veut dire
et finalement est ce que vous imaginez
que cette cotisation et puis sept
différentes en fonction de deux serrures
de ses revenus et ce qu'il faut faire
plus le 6e plus mais n'est riche que les
jaunes humaine moderne que le
financement de la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui dire vous vous payez
monsieur les cuisses des cotisations en
fonction de vos revenus
les français sont capables de comprendre
les françaises s'assurent canton le
risque le chômage ça sur contre le
risque maladie accompagne dans leurs
cotisations le risque entre guillemets
familial c'est à dire ce qui touche à la
grossesse et et bien aujourd'hui la
dépendance fait partie de notre société
en 45 encore une fois la l'espérance de
vie tu sais tu combien 62 sont trois ans
en moyenne
aujourd'hui elle est de plus de 80 ans
en moyenne pour les français ben voilà
la société change eh bien il faut savoir
parler vrai aux français alors l'autre
texte justement il concerne ce trou de
la sécu un trou creusé de 136 milliards
avec cette crise du coc vite 136
milliards que le gouvernement veut
transférer dans une caisse spéciale
la cadette ont coexisté griffe en
commission le sénat a voté pour ce
transfert en enlevant les 13 milliards
de dettes des hôpitaux est ce que vous
c'est une solution qui vous convient ou
est ce que vous y opposeraient chez
enfin on accompagnera là aussi mouvement
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix
mais l'augmentation
devant le président en charge de ce
déficit par la cad s est donc notamment
par la crds
on s'est un peu technique je m'en excuse
pour ça veut dire celle lcq qui prend en
charge la dette et pas l'état
exactement ça veut dire que c'est la
sécu qui prend en charge la dette et les
français là en l'occurrence c'est à dire
qu'on fait payer aux français à tous les
français au travers de la crds cet impôt
qui devaient disparaître en 2024
c'est le premier impôt coronavirus c'est
à dire que on augmente la cotisation de
2024 à 2030 3 7 milliards d'euros par an
c'est entendable de dire mais situation
exceptionnelle effort exceptionnel mais
pourquoi ceux qui ont le plus de moyens
ne payent rien depuis maintenant trois
ans nous dénonçons la disparition de
l'impôt sur la fortune
on dit oui mais ça rapporte rien et au
contraire ça empêche la croissance ce
n'est pas prouvée mais pourquoi faire
payer aux français à tous les français 7
milliards d'euros de cotisations
supplémentaires au travers de la crds et
ne rien demander aux revenus les plus
aisés je dirais même continué à baisser
les impôts des plus aisés au travers
notamment de la taxe d'habitation pour
les 20 % de français qui ont le plus de
moyens on marche sur la tête mais sûr et
je crois que ça c'est la sécu à l'état
de prendre en charge c'est à l'état de
prendre en charge et à l'état et donc il
est à l'état d'aller chercher des
recettes supplémentaires y compris sur
ceux et celles qui ont le plus profité
du quinquennat de monsieur macron pour
être clair le 1 % de français qui ont le
plus de revenus
autres sujets qui intéressera beaucoup
le sénateur que vous êtes c'est la
décentralisation le sénat a adopté les
propositions de votre groupe aux
nouvelles aires de la décentralisation
c'est un peu étonnant d'ailleurs je ne
cache pas que eelv on en est tous
surpris une abstention bienveillante de
la droite et du centre nous a permis de
faire passer notre proposition de
résolution j'y vois là vous étiez de
quoi il a surpris je vous cache pas que
j'étais un peu surpris oui parce qu'il y
aurait pu avoir une opposition mais
l'explication je lui ai naturellement à
posteriori à savoir que le président
larcher dans sa volonté de consensus a
estimé que ce que nous proposions était
complètement pas totalement débile donc
c'est tant mieux on a l'impression qu'il
ya quand même une
un consensus général autour de 7,2 cette
question le président de la république a
clairement identifié ce dossier comme
l'inde est prioritaire pour la fin du
mandat
est-ce que vous rejoignez l'ambition et
surtout le diable se niche dans les
détails
est ce que vous vous opposez pas sur
certaines sa façon de voir la
décentralisation alors il ya plusieurs
aspects il ya le fond et la forme
je commençais par la forme le prenant
république est favorable à un grand
changement territoriale et il l'a dit à
ce fameux déjeuner de mardi nous a dit
mais voilà moi je souhaite je reprends
l'expression je souhaite que le
département et la région passe par la
grande porte que je leur propose la
grande porte c'est une grande réforme
territoriale avant la fin du quinquennat
et
une contribution des départements des
régions grand plan de reconstruction du
pays que je vais porter jusqu'à la fin
du quinquennat discours solennel parfois
un peu grandiloquent que l'on connaît
chez le président de la république mais
les à une condition la commission s'est
pas d'élection pas d'élections en mars
si vous voulez rentrer par cette grande
porte et bien vous voulez m'accompagner
dans mon grand projet pour la nation il
n'y a pas d'élection c'est à dire que le
vulgus électorale le jeu n'en veut pas
la ficelle est un peu grosse et à dire
que dit clairement dit clairement il a
dit clairement mais si vous en voulez de
vos élections là votre petite porte là
si vous en voulez pas de problème vous
l'aurais mais je passerai au dessus de
vous l'expression était utilisée c'est à
dire que moi je défends l'intérêt
général et vous voulez vos petites
petites affaires la ficelle est grosse
je reprends l'expression parce que
chacun sait que sur toute vraisemblance
si les élections ont lieu et je le
souhaite
en mars 2021 il n'y aura aucun président
de département de la majorité
présidentielle il n'y aura aucun
président de la majorité présidentielle
pour les régions et voilà donc il faut
arrêter de nous prendre pour des buses
permettez moi l'expression
et je crois que les départements les
régions sont capables de contribuer l'on
montrait déjà pendant la crise au grand
plan de reconstruction du pays tout en
ayant leur respiration démocratique donc
la décentralisation oui mais pas au
détriment de ce qui est nécessaire à
savoir la vie démocratique normale dans
notre pays alors votre actualité
évidemment et on va revenir juste sur
les municipales vous avez sauvé
l'essentiel dans une dans une élection
qui était quand même à fort enjeu pour
les pros les socialistes sadi face à la
vague verte
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
rééquilibrage à gauche
un attelage différent pour les
prochaines essayant échéances à venir
comme le pronostiquent olives les formes
l'union et prolifique
la désunion et mortifère on l'a toujours
vu dans toutes les élections donc là il
ya eu de mémoire 36 accord entre les
verts et le ps dans les villes de plus
de 50 mille habitants 36 accord 26
derrière le ps dix derrière les verts et
quand vous regardez bien la liste on n'a
pas le temps de l'évoquer mais je crois
que il ya eu trois quarts de succès ont
été traduits dans les dents les scores
électoraux qui ne l'a reconnu dimanche
soir
j'en veux dire tant mieux l'union est
favorable à chacun et surtout une union
à gauche et les verts et j'en suis très
heureux voilà refuse toute idée
d'alliance avec avec rem est d'ailleurs
rem a fait alliance avec l air pour
contrer les alliances ps verts l'étude
mais dommage donc à ce titre que martine
aubry n'est pas réussi à attendre avec
les verts parlerait de martine aubry
après je termine je termine en vous
disant simplement que il y à une poussée
verte parce que les vertes partent les
verts partait de très bas mais quand
vous regardez bien les chiffres et je
crois que vous êtes suffisamment avertis
équilibrait les très mauvais scores
disons le de 2014 et pour venir pour la
suite on va revenir très vite à martine
aubry mais pour la suite avec les
écologistes hier olivier faure a dit ça
va frotter sur certains sujets ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que le nous n'avons pas les
mêmes conceptions
je dis souvent la queue que l'écologie
n'est pas le monopole des verts et c'est
très bien et nous n'avons pas le
monopole du coeur en falloir des
souvenirs mêlés les verts qui ont
instillé et à juste titre cette cette
nouvelle philosophie pour notre société
n'ont pas non plus le monopole du
discours écologique au lieu d'envoyer
année d'algos dire on a là quelqu'un qui
porte un vrai discours écologique et
l'écologie ce n'est pas que le
développement durable c'est une
conception de la société moi je suis
très heureux que les socialistes
aujourd'hui signe la social-écologie ils
ont raison ils ont raison que nous avons
nous même évolué mais il peut y avoir
des divergences parfois qui passent
d'ailleurs par des problèmes de
personnes disons le très simplement
relève de l'ancien et puis est-ce que
lesquels l'école le mouvement
écologiste doit aussi clarifier ses
positions sur beaucoup de thèmes je
pense aux vaccins je pense à la 5g enfin
beaucoup de positionnement sur lequel
vous pouvez vraiment vous souhaitez
voilà des sujets nous pouvons nous nous
frotter donc il peut y avoir des
différences mais sachons trouver les
voies de de l'union de là à dire
de là à dire comme certains peuvent
l'interpréter que ce qui s'est passé
dimanche soir implique automatiquement
le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de candidat
socialiste ou de la mouvance socialiste
en 2002 la réponse est non personne ne
peut le dire aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas un chèque en blanc qui est
donné depuis dimanche soir mais l'union
a montré sa force quand y'a pas d'union
et je reviens à lille il ya quelqu'un
qui est au tapis
il ya quelqu'un qui est au tapis etc
sont les verts qui ont été au tapis
dimanche soir elle est passée très près
de la frôler la correctionnelle martine
aubry comment et pourquoi finalement
cette cette guerre entre les entre les
verts et puis martine aubry alors tout
d'abord en reprenant le chemin
chronologique les verts sont dans la
majorité municipale depuis presque
trente ans aujourd'hui a parfois avec
quelques parenthèses mais il contribue à
la majorité municipale depuis pierre
mauroy c'est donc ça remonte au siècle
dernier permettez moi l'expression
ils ont toujours voulu se compter au
premier tour on aurait pu imaginer qu'il
ya un accord naturel avec martine aubry
dès le premier tour sera évité tous les
problèmes que nous avons connus là la
question qui s'est posée à la suite du
premier tour c'est que martine aubry a
fait un score qui est plus de 29% qui
est tout à fait correct mais qui est né
sais pas disons le un excellent score et
les verts ont fait eux un excellent
score et donc les appétits se sont
aiguisés et un moment donné s'il voulait
il y a eu un divorce et dans ces cas là
on se sépare moi je leur ai personne il
ya eu des problèmes de personnes nous
exigeons le eu des problèmes de voix de
d'appréciation de l'avenir
delisle et dans ces cas là il vaut mieux
se séparer et chacun sait compter martin
ritt bris aurait pu perdre
elle a gagné à la gagner de peu mais
c'est aux bouilles au bout du bout au
bout du match c'est martine aubry qui
gagne un mot très rapidement patrick
hannais nous reste très peu de temps sur
sébastien lecornu qui est qui est bien
parti pour se lancer dans la course aux
sénatoriales dans l'eure avec mon
investiture de la république en marche
est-ce que c'est compatible avec ses
fonctions de ministre une campagne
sénatoriale
écoutez je sais pas si c'est compatible
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
si moi j'ai un peu problème parce que
dans ce dans ce gouvernement il ya quand
même pas mal d'exception à cette règle
avait été imaginée imposé par nuages aux
teintes à dire que quand on est ministre
on se consacre pleinement à sa mission
de ministre j'ai été ministre et j'ai
abandonné mon mandat de président de
conseil général du nord
mais quand je vois plus darmanin et
maire de tourcoing conseillers
communautaires conseiller régional
ministre oublie qu'il ya une grosse
force de travail manifestement je suis
très fier pour pour lui et pour et pour
le nord vers la parenthèse
mais sébastien lecornu essaimé sur les
corps nous éviter qu'il va faire
campagne auprès des bassins l'aube le
mélange des genres il ya eu l'opération
mangouste lecornu actuellement qui est
lancé c'est aussi la prévention mangou
c'était kennedy par rapport à cuba quand
on connaît la suite
et l'opération main gauche le corps nu
c'est je viens au sénat et je prendrai
le sénat peut-être en 2023 dans le cadre
de grandes alliances je pense qu'il
risque d'avoir quelques désillusions